Đi thôi, đầy mạnh phát triển qua công nghệ đổi mối sáng tạng trên đổi số, trên đổi sáng
phải sáng đầy ở độc lực chính là chục của quân trọng nhất là nên tạng chính lợ
đến nâng cao nâng sớm lợ đọc, chất lợ thân trở và sức cạnh tranh của rằng
mối mô ngành điều phương cần ở những thành cám mối mối, chục tâm đổi mối sáng tạng
khu công nghệ cao chính quyền số, xá hội số và công ra số
tạng mối trường còn lợi cho công đổi mối sáng tạng và khởi giật phát triển
Bà khi đồ phát triển kết tổ hạ tận lần gồn, hiện đại
Bà những nhiên đồ các công trình cho việc của ra hạ tận gồm chứ lợh
hạ tận năng lợng, hạ tận lâu dịch sức
Mối mộ ngành việc phương cần tổ chức cạnh trình kì đồ cáo điểm, để giải quyết dịch điểm
Các sự an cầu đọc cáo điện, để khơi thông nguồn lực cho phát triển